We'll just waft it under your
nose and you give me--
Oh, sweat.
Smells awful.
Musky.
Not good.
Another go.
No.
Most people think that their
senses are quite reliable and
objective, so you would expect
that the same substance should
smell the same to different
people.
It smells like flowers.
Some people don't
smell anything.
It smells good.
This isn't always the case.
For example, this stuff called
androstenone to some people
smells like vanilla or floral.
Kind of foral.
Vanilla.
I think the men are all saying
vanilla, aren't they?
Hibiscus flower.
Flower.
Hibiscus.
That's very specific.
Thank you.
I got it now, it's vanilla.
Vanilla for you as well.
OK.
It's sweet vanilla.
Really?
But to me it smells like
stale urine or
stale sweat or something.
Unpleasant.
It's unpleasant.
Men's urinals.
In fact, this does occur
naturally in human sweat.
It also occurs in other
animals where it's a
pheromone, so it attracts
members of the opposite sex.
And the difference in perception
of this chemical is
down to small variations
in the DNA of a gene on
chromosome 17.
That gene is OR7D4.
And this is just one example
of those tiny genetic
differences that change the
way we are and how we
perceive the world.
OK so hands up if this
smells sweaty to you.
And floral.